Donald Trump has still not taken questions
from reporters.
It's been about a month now.
It's been since before the election that we
have not actually seen Donald Trump take questions
from reporters yesterday.
Suddenly, haphazardly, a presidential press
conference was called.
It was in the briefing room at the White House
and it lasted.
This is not a mistake.
OK, 64 seconds, not minutes, 64 seconds is
all that.
It was assembling the press corps for Donald
Trump to take no questions and delusional
brag about medical advancements.
And the Dow Jones Industrial Average hitting
30000 during trading yesterday.
Take a look at this.
Now, normally I say this thing went on an
hour.
It went on an hour and a half.
I can't play the whole thing for you.
I am playing the entire press conference for
you today.
OK, not a portion of it.
Let's start.
Well, thank you very much.
And I just want to congratulate everybody.
The stock market, Dow Jones Industrial Average
just hit 30000, which is the highest in history.
We've never broken 30000, and that's despite
everything that's taken place with the pandemic.
I'm very thrilled with what's happened on
the vaccine front.
That's been absolutely incredible.
I find it sort of hilarious that Donald Trump
comes in and says he wants to congratulate
everybody, congratulate everybody for doing
what exactly?
I mean, just a bizarre start.
A comedy of errors, like every little detail
is hilarious and pathetic.
That was the first 23 seconds of the 64.
Let's now get to more of this.
I'm showing you everything.
We're going to pick it up right where we left
off.
It's nothing like that has ever happened medically.
And I think people are acknowledging that
and it's having a big effect.
But the stock market's just broken.
30000 never been broken.
That number, that's a sacred number.
Thirty thousand.
Nobody thought they'd ever see it.
So, OK, I have to stop once more.
30000 is a sacred number.
What?
What is he talking about, how is that even
a remotely sensible thing to say, it's sacred
to get to 30000?
What?
I don't even know what that's supposed to
mean.
And then here are the last 25 seconds.
That's the ninth time since the beginning
of 2020.
And it's the fourth time that we've broken
records in during the Trump administration.
And I just want to congratulate all the people
within the administration that work so hard.
And most importantly, I want to congratulate
the people of our country because there are
no people like you.
Thank you very much, everybody.
Thank you.
So that is the full press conference, 64 seconds
with Mike Pence standing behind him with this
kind of Dufy smirk on his face to say congratulations
to the American people, I guess, for hitting
the sacred number of 30000 in the Dow Jones
Industrial Average and to claim that we've
seen medical advancements like we've never
seen before thanks to his presidency and to
still take no questions.
How bizarre is this?
This you know, I am I am not a person who
lacks empathy.
Donald Trump seems unable to experience the
feeling of empathy.
I don't lack empathy.
And in watching these very sad 64 seconds,
I actually came close to thinking about maybe
feeling slightly bad for Trump, just deflated,
grasping for anything that he can say or do
to keep his grip on relevance.
As the transition to Joe Biden's presidency
continues.
And it seems like Trump feels that slipping
away like grant grains on a sandy beach slipping
through one's fingers, it's strange to see
Donald Trump keep trying to sell himself to
the American people after losing an election.
And one other funny note.
Back during the transition period into Trump's
administration, Donald Trump took credit for
the rise in the stock market in November and
December and early January.
Remember, Barack Obama was still president
then, but Donald Trump took credit and said,
no, no.
Once I got elected, stocks started going up
even before I was inaugurated.
Thanks to me, that's the opposite of what
he's doing here.
He is now saying even though the stock market
is going up after Joe Biden has been elected,
he, as the lame duck president, still gets
credit for the stock market going up.
At this point, you know, hypocrisy is dead
and double standards have no meaning with
this administration.
But just sort of like as a side note, outgoing
here, not even worth arguing with him, not
even worth arguing with Trump.
It's about, you know, don't let the door hit
you on the way out.
But yet another one of these instances of
Donald Trump holding himself to a completely
different standard than he held Barack Obama
to.
And that applies to Joe Biden and that applies
to Hillary Clinton.
And it applies to essentially anybody that
would be seen as not friendly to Donald Trump
in the space of politics.
So he's slowly being deflated.
I still doubt that we will ever again see
Donald Trump do a full actual press conference
before leaving office where he takes questions
and he's not even going to be punished for
it by his followers because they will say
he's right not to take questions.
The media colluded with Biden and they're
all against him and they're fake.
Why would he give them the ratings of letting
them ask him questions?
So that's what they'll say.
Trump will sort of fade away and he may.
I mean, listen, we may after Christmas, as
has been suggested, he may just leave DC and
that'll be it.
No appearance at the inauguration would not
be at all surprising, although for for optics
sake, I would be fascinated to see Donald
Trump at the inauguration of President Joseph
R. Biden Jr..
We've got a great show for you today.
Today will be like a Friday show because it
is the last show of the week.
We are off tomorrow and Friday for the Thanksgiving
holiday, but we are here today.
One more show and then it will be on a little
bit
of
a break.